my name is George stag I'm a software
engineer at posit um and today I'm going
to be chairing this session which is uh
named tidy up your models um so the
first person we have today to speak to
you is Ryan timy um and I'm going to
pass straight on to him to get started
thank
you thank
you so last night at the reception
someone ran up to me super excited to
meet me I was like yes I made it I'm
nerd famous but they thought I was
Hadley Wickham so um just putting that
out there I'm not Hadley Wickam my name
is Ryan timy I am a lead data scientist
at the LEGO Group uh my team and I build
models to help our business understand
how all of our marketing our trade
promotions our product launches all that
impacts our sales and our brand Health
I've been at the LEGO Group for almost 5
years and over that time the field of
data science has really changed
as you might have noticed our studio is
now posit um my managers are always
talking about production and if you
checked out the title of my talk before
you sat down our models are now tidy and
this change can be challenging
especially when it impacts our work but
it can also be kind of fun and rewarding
to rethink how you dat you do your
day-to-day job so this talk was about
that um some of the recent fun and
challenges I had while adapting to the
changing world of data science or the
LEGO Group so let's start with that
first Adventure
um and I'm going to call my changes
Adventures it's more fun so um when I
joined uh the LEGO Group my first job
was to build an r package to do our
modeling better and I did that I built a
package it was simple but it worked and
it answered some important questions for
our business for no special reason at
all I'm going to represent that model on
the screen as a red Lego
brick no reason uh and then over the
four years we had to do more with this
package uh we had to add ways to add
more data to the package and the model
we had to add more pre-processing we had
to add more post-processing uh and then
we had to do more things to add business
value to make sure our stakeholders are
actually using the models and driving
change in the
organization uh then we kept doing this
over and over and over more data more
pre-processing pre-processing functions
more post-processing functions and
eventually our pretty simple model and
package looked a lot more like this and
this happened because we grew our
package organically it did everything we
needed to do it ran some pretty awesome
models but it was getting very difficult
for my team and I to navigate this and
grow with and have this package grow
with us so as we need to make more
changes and add more things we need to
find all those connections and where to
put each new Step um and we it came to
the point where we weren't effective
data scientists and we needed to make a
change um and so four years later we had
mattur we knew exactly what we needed at
our package and it was time to start
over so to do that we identified titem
models
tidy models is a framework that adds
organization to your models so it takes
that big messy pile of bricks and it
Stacks them I never used tidy models
before and and I needed to use it on my
job uh so I use this book to help me by
Max and Julia who you will see on the
stage in a few minutes um and I um so
today's talk it's it's not a tutorial
I'm not going to show you much code I'm
not going to show you how to really get
started with tidy models but after uh
this conference and if you're still
super excited about models definitely
check out this book check out these
websites and it will do have everything
you need to get started uh cuz that's
what I did I took this book I followed
it cover to cover took all those
examples appli them to my work at the
LEGO Group and it was a really good way
to get started with tidy models and to
get started rereading my
package so tidy models itself is a
collection of packages and each of those
packages really helped solve some big
problem I was having with my models so
if you look at that red preprocess or
sorry sorry the the yellow
pre-processing brick uh recipes was a
huge help here so pre-processing is a
step that takes your raw data that might
be human
readable uh adds feature engineering and
gets it ready to be machine readable for
your model in my old package the one
with all the the big pile of Lego bricks
I had manually written a bunch of
functions in uh using D plier and tidar
to do this pre-processing and then every
time I need to access my data at
different parts of the modeling process
I'd grab those uh call that function it
would run through all the pre-processing
steps um but as my data sets got bigger
and bigger uh it this got to be like it
was a lot of overhead it took way too
long for this to run my modeling was
models were taking a lot of time to run
it was also getting very difficult to
control for data leakage at each each of
those steps so pre-processing um sorry
recipes solves that where you kind of
just list out your instructions in one
spot and then the Tidy model packages
will call that whenever needed uh
whenever the model models need your
data let's look take a look at the red
brick right here and parsnip was a huge
help here so this red brick is the core
chunk of code in my uh package that runs
the modeling
algorithm uh in my old package um this
chunk of code was deeply nested in a
series of functions or my Lego analogy
that one red brick was buried deep in a
pile of other bricks and so every time I
needed to call um
that make any edits to that model uh
either small edits or big mod edits I
also had to change every single function
that it relied upon it parip solves this
by instead providing one a uniform
syntax to all the different modeling
types in uh R so whether it's X boost or
it's uh basian model uh and with that it
helps you make sure your modeling
process is modular so now I can swap out
that red brick with other features or
swap out the modeling algorithm entirely
and not have to worry as much about the
data and the pre-processing and the
postprocessing all the other steps very
minor changes there if I could swap out
that red brick that was a huge
help tune again was a huge help um my
first time around uh I had manually
written a simulated kneeling algorithm
to help me do my hyperparameter tuning
and that was a really good experience
for me I got to learn how the algorithm
Works uh but this time around I didn't
want to do that again it was a lot of
work and I knew how to do it I didn't
want to manually write that a second
time so I just used tune
postprocessing I use broom broom takes
all your uh raw model output and makes
it into a tidy format so you can grab
your residuals easily you can grab your
coefficients very easily and probably my
favorite though is workflows workflows
takes a bunch of those bricks and clicks
them together um now you have one single
object that you can use for your
modeling process and then that object
can then be passed into other functions
to help dry business value or it can
even be passed into a production
environment and vver can help you
here so in the end I completely
Rewritten all my code uh my package
still did the same thing though it did
it in a lot more organized way it was a
lot easier for my team and I to uh now
evolve grow this package and evolve with
it so now as we get more requests from
our stakeholders we have to add more
things to the package uh we know exactly
where in this pipeline it
goes but my favorite part is that this
is all the advertised benefits of tight
end models this is what the book will
tell you as my team and I started using
this more and more uh we discovered a
bunch of new benefits that were not told
to us uh they were all the surprise
benefits from using tiing models so this
brings us to our Second Adventure and as
you know sequels are always better than
the
original no laughing um so we had
Rewritten my modeling package uh it was
a lot more organized now we discovered
all these new benefits uh this is going
to sound weird but I was really helped
by what tiend models could not do for me
so I'm I'm a data scientist but I'm also
a Lego data scientist so a lot of my
value as a lead comes from knowing how
the world of data science fits into the
Lego business and tidy models really
help me do this better so wherever I
could I use the open source tools
available with tidy models and there's
of course more packages than than this
but for Simplicity I use tidy model
packages wherever I could and those
functions wherever I could and by doing
this I saved a bunch of time and I got
to use time to focus on my expertise
which is a little bit of modeling but
it's a lot of Lego I know everything
about Lego and I know how the world of
leg or how Lego can use these models so
I got to spend all this extra time use I
earned from using TTY models to focus on
what I could add to these models to
really help the LEGO Group so for
example if you look at pre-processing
again uh recipes is essentially a bunch
of these step functions that you can
pipe together to transform your data uh
and these are step functions that are
used by data scientist everywhere for
example step normalize will take your
numerical data give it a mean of zero
and standard deviation of one and these
are very common things that data science
T everywhere
use um and this freed up my time to
focus on my I could use custom set
functions because in my domain I have
some very specific Transformations I
have to use I'm in marketing we have to
add carryover effects to our data we
have to add diminishing returns and
these are more specific to my domain so
I used all my free time well not free
time but extra time that uh that I
earned from using the open source tools
to make my custom set functions and this
really added the Lego twist to my open
or to my new modeling package and I
found opportunities to add this Lego
value ad everywhere everywhere across
this modeling pipeline uh for example
with my data our team has thousands of
possible data series we could put in our
models you can't put that much data in
your models so we had to spend a lot of
time figure out which data sources
belong in our models so I was able to
write tools to help us do that better
the modeling process I could spend more
time making sure my model was better
specified um making sure our residuals
were behaving better post-processing is
huge for us uh we have to take all of
our raw model output and make it make
sense for the organization like
calculating media uplifts and
calculating return on investments coming
out of the models we have a lot of
functions here I got to spend a lot of
time on this very important part um of
the modeling process business value had
more time to work with our stakeholders
by leveraging open source tools and then
on the flip side when you leverage these
open source tools you get their help
with all the bugs you Outsource your bug
squashing because you're going to have
hit fewer errors in the process uh and
when you do hit errors there's a lot
more documentation out there on how to
solve those errors rather if you're
writing your own functions and your old
manual modeling functions it's a lot
harder to solve some of these
errors so by leveraging this open source
uh community and tools whenever I could
I just became a much better Lego data
scientist I got to make sure that that
our models were working well for my
organization another big benefit I saw
was speed so no one else is going to
stand on the stage and tell you how fast
Tiding models is uh Julia warned me
about that it's not it's it adds
overhead but actually by the swap we
actually unlocked a lot of speed in a
few different ways and I want to talk
about those um with our process so since
I wasn't running my own DLI code and my
tar uh code over and over for my data
processing my functions just ran a lot
faster uh and that was very noticeable
to us and it was a huge win when we
discovered that um our algorithm uh we
had originally in our models we used
basian models we had manually written St
code to do that um that was really
awesome because we got to customize
every piece of that code uh or that
model but uh with tidy models our stand
arm works a lot better with parsnip uh
and tidy models and that's a bunch of St
or stand models pre-written and
pre-compiled by experts out there so we
leveraged those models that algorithm
Instead This Time Around and that really
sped us up and then just our ways of
working was a lot faster um so with the
swap satti models and the workflows
process uh we were able to keep now
every single part of the modeling
process and uh development process on
the same platform we can basically do
our entire developments in one R
notebook and that really just saved us
tons saves our data scientists tons of
time iterating over models developing
models because we could move a lot more
quickly and uh without switching
environments and everything um so I can
quantify this change we had a batch of
models for one project that used to take
about 30 minutes to run from start to
finish uh they now they take just 60
seconds uh that's a 30-fold increase for
us and a really measurable increase that
helps our team work better if we add
that into with the earlier example of
the Lego value ad we have a pretty
awesome list of
benefits uh as you know though sometimes
benefits come with costs this was no
exception here um we did have a few
extra new hurdles with the Tidy model
swap um and so we had to kind of rethink
our ways of working so we're used to
solving some specific problems one way
for four years we had to come up with
some new ways um for one example is that
algorithm when I when we SWA from our
manually written Stan code to our Stan
arm we gave up a lot of control uh with
Stan we could customize really every
single prior distribution type based on
a variable type and when we swap to r
stand arm we a lot more limited and what
can do but whenever we came across these
types of challenges we were able to kind
of step back can we re can we solve this
problem that we're used to solving one
way a new way and every time we came
across these problems the answer is yes
we could work with this uh and by far
everywhere the benefits of the tid AEL
swap really outran the cost so no
regrets
there um and this brings us to our final
part so we had re our code it was a lot
more organized we had all these new
benefits that we weren't expecting uh
there's a Twist though I was making all
these changes to a live product so we
had stakeholders we were working with in
real time so this is my stealth
Adventure it's my stealth Adventure
because my original goal was to sneak
into a product in the middle of the
night um hopefully no one noticed me and
I SWA out the old models for the new
ones and hopefully no one noticed this
kind of like this I'm Tom Cruz coming
with my tidy models um and we could have
succeeded with this we could have
swapped out our old models for the new
ones and no one would have known the
different but along the way we noticed
that all the benefits of my team
experience with tidy models we could
actually share those benefits with the
stakeholders so rather than sneak and
swap out the models we could actually
get them just as excited as we
were and we did this on a few different
areas one is that we could build better
models now so tidy models um are written
by experts across the globe and modeling
experts who are better at modeling than
I am so I'd be silly to ignore their
expertise so once we knew that with the
new package we could reproduce our old
results that was an important step for
us uh we then took it a step further and
used all the tools that tidy models
offered us uh to build better models so
we got better residuals we could get
better fits um and those so now our
stakeholders did see some changing
numbers but it was for a good reason and
we can talk them through those changing
numbers and sell them on
it uh tit models enabled faster more
frequent updates
so
um sorry since our data scientists could
work faster uh we could work faster with
their stakeholders so as long as our
stakeholders keep on feeding us new data
and new ideas we can work with them
almost in real time to take their ideas
and data spin it through the models and
see what happens is this change worth it
or not and this is this has improved our
stakeholder engagement so
much um the ability to automate and to
put into production in our old modeling
package production still had some very
manual steps I was getting my fingers
and all those steps um but now with tidy
models it's a lot easier to do that so
we can work with our Engineers work with
that workflows object automate our data
and flows pass them that object and they
can help us put into production a lot
more easily than we could
before um probably my favorite as a data
scientist is that we can now answer more
complex questions with these ti- models
um so with ti- day models is a lot
easier to make assumptions uh and change
assumptions on the Fly and so for
example our stakeholders love what if
scenarios so what if we had doubled
social media spend last Christmas or
what if we had moved this promotion a
few weeks earlier what would have
happened so now we can go into our
modeling pipeline go to that green brick
at the top Shake around some data and it
will flow through all the other rest of
the modeling steps even including the
trained model uh and tell us exactly
what the model thinks would have
happened in these scenarios uh so being
able to give almost realtime simulations
and optimizations to our stakeholders
was a huge win for us and then finally
I'm the is my day-to-day job so I'm
still learning these new uh I'm still
unlocking new value of their
stakeholders um and so ask me again in a
few months I'll probably have some brand
new lists of benefits to share with you
um so that's it thank you so much this
was of course a talk about tidy models
uh also really about just embracing
change in data science that change can
be scary um but we came out so much
benefit uh better for our stakeholders
and I benefited um so thank you and if
you want to talk about tidan Ms
afterwards find me thank you so much
thank
[Applause]
you